hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the hundred thousand genomes
project I am Judy Oracle blab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provide our virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning we also like to acknowledge the
sea and en media group for help with
programming and promotion of the event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on a CD button located
in the bottom left hand corner of your
web page and follow the process of
obtaining your credits I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Tim
Hubbard dr. Hubbard is a professor of
bioinformatics head of the department of
medical and molecular genetics at King's
College London and director of
bioinformatics for Kings Health Partners
King's College London he's also head of
genome analysis at genomics England the
company set up by the UK Department of
Health to execute the hundred thousand
genomes project which aims to mainstream
the use of whole genome sequence
analysis for treatment in the UK
national health service NHS if you would
like more information about our speaker
please click on his photo image
top right the planners for this event
has stated no relevant financial
relationships however dr. Kevin Davies
did disclose that he is a scientific
advisory board member for pathway
genomics and is on a speaker's bureau
for Harry Walker incorporated and that
neither constitute a conflict of
interest although dr. Hubbard has
indicated that he has a relative
financial relationship with genomics
kingdom limited this does not constitute
a conflict of interest because genomics
engli mitad is wholly owned by the UK
government and does not need the
definition of a commercial interest I
will now turn it over to dr. Hubbard for
his presentation thanks very much so I'm
very happy to be here sitting in
genomics in room right now in London I'm
going to talk to you about 100,000
Genome Project so first thing I think
it's useful to say since there's an
international audience a little bit
about UK genomics and health care kind
of 101 so obviously UK has been a
leading figure in the human genome
project with third of the imaging and
big sequence of the book Trust Sanger
Institute where I was headed informatics
for many years it's also of course led
on the hungry the thousand genomes
project which was the sort of last set
of large-scale genomes publicly
available most recently it's carried out
the UK 10k project which is a set of a
cohort of patients cohort of individuals
who have conditions and weather is
phenotype information all of those
projects though have been low coverage
at least the thousand and ten thousand
project the UK also has something called
UK biobank which sounds quite analogous
to the precision medicine initiative 1
million cohorts being planned in the US
so this is half a million individuals
forty to sixty nine year olds and they
were recruited you know recruitment
finished in two thousand levels so those
patients
is there not patients and those
participants have been quite heavily
phenotyped they haven't been genome
sequence although they have been
genotyped that's a collection which
actually is a is available for research
inquiries to carry out so there's a
biobank that we have in the UK now the
match emotional health service the NHS
so we're a single payer organization in
the UK obviously everything paid for
taxation there's actually four services
across UK so I'm talking about genomics
England which is doing a hundred
thousand genomes in Vienna the zone of
England so under NHS England and the
health system is 110 billion pounds
annual budget about 1.4 million
employees so it's a very large entity
the NHS in England so the history of
this there's a long history towards
trying to link health and research and
to bring in genomics so many many
countries are interested in can we use
the information is stored in electronic
health records and get that available
for a search and so there's multiple
initiatives but one of the most recent
ones is the osky health board which was
set up to enable research on top of the
investments in the UK and electronic
health records that led to the launch of
the CPR d the clinical practice research
data link in 2011 and founding the far
institute which is set up to build
capacity around usurpation records on
the other side there's trying to get
genomics into health so in 2009 there
was a house of lords report on generic
medicine basically flagging that after
the cost of the initial genome now
prices had come down to the point where
it was feasible to start thinking about
putting putting whole genome sequencing
into the health service that led to the
creation of the industry
the group which was in the Department of
Health to plan how you might execute
genomics in the health service year
later the UK the government changed and
launched a life science strategy which
that was incorporating many aspects of
trying to make the UK a better place for
research in pharmaceutical areas and a
year later an update of that the
announcement included the announcement
of a hundred thousand years project so
they end up 2012 2013 genomics England
was launched as the entity to run the
hundred thousand genomes project so the
hundred thousand genomes project firstly
you can compare it with UK biobank 100k
is a treatment project it's really an
NHS transformation project to try and
get treated get g whole genomes into the
health service project is entirely whole
genome sequencing at a clinical grade
that's more than 30 x coverage focus on
rare diseases and form of trios cancer
employment new normal chima pairs
because he's a timeline already
mentioned the setting up phase we had a
pilot in 2014 but the main thing i'm
going to talk about is the structure of
the main program which has been started
since the beginning of last year so it's
got a number of objectives obviously
it's to sequence one hundred thousand
genomes but each of those genomes it's
hope that they will lead to improvements
of health for those individuals being
sequence on the other side it's also
hoped that the existence of a hundred
thousand genomes and we need to
interpret that will stimulate the
economy stimulate her setting up of
enterprises that will build experience
in terms of interpretation in the UK
it's also meant to leave a legacy of
infrastructure able to handle the huge
amounts of data involved and human
capacity capability within the health
service to handle rather as well and
then finally of course it's a large data
set hope this will stimulate genomics
research now if you can you can think
about the process for doing this whole
business starting from a DNA sample
ending outlook clinical action and you
could look at that pipeline and build
all the components of the pipeline but
Gino meeting was set up as a lightweight
organization and the idea was that
rather than build everything from
scratch it would outsource procure
components and so to make the model
rather like this where you separate out
sequencing component from the
interpretation component and then the
feeding back into the health service so
that's really what's been built over the
last couple of years you have genomics
England in the middle first agent of
course to work out who was going to do
sequencing so we had a bake-off where we
sent some samples to a number of
companies they returned sequence data on
disks and we assess that for quality and
coverage that informed the contract
which was eventually awarded to alumina
so one of the principles behind this
whole project is that the samples the
data doesn't move out of England but
it's it's a health service project so in
terms of privacy everything must happen
within England and so this involves
aluminum making investments into the UK
to build a sequencing facility that's
actually going to be hosted at Hingston
where the sale Institute is in a
building that's being built by the
Wellcome Trust has been leased to
alumina to fulfill the contract so the
next thing you need which is arguably
harder is to get a flow of patients
consented individuals where
the sequencing by whole genomes will
lead to an improvement in their health
care so this is being managed through in
the main project through NHS England so
NHS England has contracted number the
creation of a number of genome medicine
centers in the National Health Service
so because it's a national health
service the aim is for to have access to
this across the country and so these are
essentially regional centers that were
selected as a lead organization but then
this local timidly partners involves
around 90 hospitals about a third of the
health service now involved some level
in providing the flow event of consented
individuals into the program so then the
other thing you need of course in this
particular area is somewhere to put the
data and handle data and so again this
is procured through in fact a government
framework because the government has its
own secured up if data centers these are
now structured around cloud private
cloud computing so commercial providers
will provide the infrastructure under
contract with in a secure center so
that's the model it's been adopted now
so you have now the flow of DNA to
alumina and you have the flow of data
into the data center as one other thing
that's being taken out of from the
genome medicine centers and that's
phenotype goes well this is a major
other side of the program we don't just
want to collect sample you want to have
a very clear statement of the patients
who are being brought into the program
based on unmet clinical need so the idea
is there are already existing processes
in the health service for doing single
gene tasks panel tests and we want
patients to have already gone through
those processes so we don't end up
sequencing whole genomes when
wrestling's existing tests which can be
deployed so there's an eligibility
criteria attached
or the rare disease conditions for
example that we are currently in
allowing to be brought into the program
patients who meet that eligibility
criteria that also needs to be data
collected to make it very clear what the
phenotype is of their condition and
that's linked each of those disease
areas also has a gene panel associated
which is also curated so the data models
they're ready to capture phenotype
information so hpo is one standard part
of that definition each of the data
models there's a clear definition of
what phenotype terms we expect the way
this is all managed is through a data
model catalog which holds all wrecked a
term in a database and can be curated so
that we can evolve these models over
time as it becomes clearer from a
combination of views from experts
clinicians and researchers what's the
best set of data to allow each Gina me
to be interpreted and also being used
for a search now the way they've
database operates is that the curation
who can be exported in here format xml
external specification of the data
that's required to be reported and that
can also feed into a clinical interface
so the genome medicine centers they can
populate this data for each of the
patients they've consented either
through this clinical interface based on
clinical or they can write an XML
specification directly out of their
electronic health record system so this
we're basically supporting extraction of
data from electronic health systems into
this program so that gives you the feed
filling of clinical data now
we also were inputting various other
types of data which is collected
elsewhere in the health system as
hospital episode statistics there's a
registry which collects for example
cancer registry information that will
also be brought in but there's a sort of
secondary research data source prime now
the primary data that we need to
interpret those genomes is being
collected directly as I've described now
once you've got all that data in the
data center obviously you need to
interpret those genomes and again we're
rather than building our own
interpretation pipeline where we're
managing a series of interpretation
companies we've been doing that through
another bake-off another competition to
evaluate different groups in this field
so back in 2014 we ran a competition
with 30 different groups taking part we
made a short list of ten groups and
we've now selected from those offered
initial contracts to do provide those
interpretation services now I mentioned
earlier on that there's this intention
to stimulate the economy so there's
another parallel effort involved of
providing grants to a few companies to
stimulate activity new cane development
of this sphere of in genome
interpretation so those companies have
to have been selected they run their
interpretation services within the data
center and it's the same model justice
as samples can't go out of England the
Illumina has to be based in England here
the data doesn't go out of the data
center any service has to run inside
that data center to provide a clinical
report now feedback to the NHS it's not
analyzing a whole genome for all the
possible future conditions it's very
specific these are all ill people with
clear phenotypes and we want primary
findings to diagnose their actual
condition this is limited number of
secondary findings which
can be reported but that's based on the
consent of individual rights an option
for the individuals to choose whether
they want these secondary findings it's
a very very limited set where there's
action ability in the health service and
it's you know it's a very clear risk
allele now some figures so we're
currently up this is a bit out of date
that's more like 6000 genome whole
genome sort of in sequence and
transferred into our data center and
there's more obviously patients that
have been consented through the initial
11g no medicine centers the GM
interpretation providers three out of
four of these these forwarded have been
selected have been brought into the data
center and one of them is actively
running genomics England's providing a
wrapping around that the companies have
to produce reports in a fairly
standardized way and they also have to
combine that with information from gene
panels genes that be curated as being
likely to be associated with each
condition so this producing degree of
standardization despite to thank you
have different providers so essentially
we're going to provide reports back but
also do an evaluation in this first
eight thousand genomes of how these
different companies perform and we'll be
looking for new companies in the future
bringing in additional testing a rubber
of providers over time now I mentioned
this the data model development I
mentioned the model catalog and a lab
that secure a from the gene models
similarly the gene panels are being
curated the sets of genes that in four
to be associated with each disease and
so there's a panel app which you can
view and you can also apply to be an
expert reviewer and this is basically
has all the diseases that are currently
in the eligible data set for collection
and it has you know ranking of how
people have reviewed the different genes
that are associated with each of those
conditions
now this brings me to because all those
experts they're a mixture of clinicians
and researchers Matt links to the
research part of this whole design so
important part of the hundred thousand
genomes is that it's all under a
research protocol under a new
designation bioresource in the UK which
allows us both to do clinical treatment
and to do research and so that allows me
contacting collection of an extra
biobank sample which is available for
future omics studies so it's real
combination one dataset being used for
two purposes and if you look at this
diagram so this now extends this diagram
so the way that the research is being
organized is through what we're calling
genomic same and clinical interpretation
partnership so this is whole load P I is
about two and a half thousand p is
mainly from the UK but also outside the
UK which are coming together to form
domains working in particular areas
which I'll describe in a minute the main
principle is of those partnerships they
also have exactly the same constraints
the analysis has to be done inside the
data center there isn't any export of
that data this is similarly and that
data as a consortium can also access the
biobank repository sample as well that
they can propose investigations that
they might do using that sample parallel
was also something called gene
consulting which is a set of companies
and they're running exactly the same way
in a pre-competitive framework accessing
data but again they can only analyze
data from within the data center so the
clinical turbo tation partnerships
divided up into mains so there's a set
of specific domains around particular
diseases so in cancer and great diseases
unknown as cross-cutting domains looking
at different generic analytical
processes using data to try and improve
those processes the goals here are
obviously doing basic research but also
to drive up interpretation of those
individual Gina
so here we have we anticipate maybe the
diagnostic rate will be increased from
what it is right now which is probably
around 20 25 cents and individuals using
the existing diagnostic tests in the
health service to maybe fifty percent
that's all these fifty percent of
individuals who are going to get a
diagnosis because it's not clear looking
at their genomes where the actual parent
of interest is hoped and the clinical
interpretation partnerships will be able
to look at those groups of variants
across groups and individuals and
improve the interpretation improved the
curation of which genes are volved in
those conditions so up to now we've
launched a set of domains with the pru
to set of domains around to different
cancers who different raise these areas
number of cross-cutting domains and an
ethics domain and a validation d'alene
and this will be evolved over time none
of these these groups are just getting
going in terms of working out their
research plans applying for external
funding etc now so if you look at this
whole model I think you can see that you
can kind of simplify this down basic
premise behind this is one so data on
the health service side where it's used
both for interpretation and research so
that's the kind of model rebuilding here
and it can be putting potentially a
future way of doing Health Service
research and treatment and combine your
way now it does lead to considerations
about data sharing for example we've
been used to in the human genome project
and the thousand genomes project being
able to just download data and run
analysis whenever we like as researchers
it's got slightly more difficult with
these large-scale data sets which
include phenotype data such as you know
such as any any of the studies which
involves patients with phenotype
information because they're stalled in
DB gap
EGA you have to go through approval
processes to get access to that data you
have to show that you can hold it on a
secure system for example in this case
in some ways it's hard in some ways it's
easier because you won't be able to
download the data and that in some ways
that's more practical because it's
easier now to bring the algorithms to
the data because the data is so large
but it also means that we're protecting
individuals privacy by telling them that
the data isn't going to be distributed
so they haven't have confidence that we
know what the data is being useful that
we can watch researchers researchers can
also work in a unified environment and
deploy their algorithms there to do
analysis so that's the model that we're
moving towards you think it's going to
be a future model for difficult
healthcare data now one of the risks it
is that it will generate a set of war
gardens and causing very rare conditions
it's really none able to be able to
collect data from around the world as
projects like decipher have managed very
successfully to do but it should still
be possible to you know bridge that gap
even if you can't distribute walk data
through federated analysis and so there
is this now this organization call the
Global Alliance for genomics and health
which is building software
infrastructure is already deployed
things called beacons which make it
possible to have closed datasets which
can be asked questions we don't reveal
information about the individuals in
those collections but do allow a degree
of data or information sharing so I
think that's the kind of an evolution
but pipeline is to sort of future to
making sure we can do effective
information sharing without sharing the
underlying raw information that protects
people's privacy now is one other aspect
i've mentioned which is worth pointing
out i said that the health service in
england has 1.4 million people
if the hundred thousand is really just
the ban guard of moving into whole
genome sequences in a health service
then we have to do training and so part
of the money has been allocated hundred
million pounds that was initially
allocated to genomics even went to
health education able to provide and the
C courses teaching and this has also
been deployed across the country you've
got nine different universities
including by own Kings teaching MSC
specifically around genomic medicine so
the overall picture is that this project
hundred thousand project and genomics
England it's providing a
transformational catalyst for the NHS
through the genome medicine centre
contracts it's leading to
standardization of secondary care data
collection within the health service and
piloting this dual purpose data center
model to allow secure usage of clinical
information and provide a way of
deploying interpretation services both
for research and also for treatment now
if I put my other hat on because I'm
genomics in on part time also at Kings
health partners and king's college if
you look at it from the point of view
ring and genome medicine center there
well as many advantages of being part of
the hundred thousand project and the
sort of infrastructure that's being
constructed for the future so this
brings us in to the expertise of using
very large whole scale or gene of data
in a health system because Kings are
partners of course is one of these
academic health science centers that is
a university and a set of hospitals it
takes it into these national data sets
as opposed to just our local data sets
for analysis it does drive the
leveraging of electronic health record
systems you know to be able to support
the requirements of the contract with
genomics England and NHS England it's
leading us to think about better ways of
structuring
EHR so that we can capture data in a
more systematic way as part of a drive
in the UK as a whole I think finally the
intrud one of the interesting things is
it will drive the possibility of
developing your own apps for decision
support because now you're going to have
a set of genomes stalled which are
potentially available on demand for
interpretation it's a small set right
now because it's just the hundred
thousand data but data is going to be
stored and is potentially there so that
it can be reused if a patient comes back
with a different condition or even
something well they just is a potential
pharmacogenomic analysis of which is
most appropriate drug so I think if you
take this model you can think of adding
one additional line which is worth of
genome medicine sensors potentially fire
off apps which run in the data center on
the genome and provide a decision
support output that feeds directly back
into the EHR of those medicine settings
and in terms of the way of thinking
about this if you think of research that
tends to happen in hospitals and
university settings it's about
collections of samples it has been about
collections of samples where you've got
partial data genotypes exomes low
coverage genomes and doing analysis
across those to find patterns to look
for disease relationships but we're not
going to switch for this where every
where every sample is sequence the
clinical grading so you can still do
that analysis to look for and used to
disease relationships that you can also
look at every individual and say what
can I say about that individual that can
feed back into their clinical treatment
as well I think that's another direction
of research that we should expand to
encourage people to think about
interpreting individuals and feeding
back directly into their treatment as
opposed to just looking for patterns
which were feeds a drug development
pathway in a very slow maybe 20 years
ahead sort of research purposes
so that's a hundred thousand genomes
project hundred thousand whole genome
sequences being collected in a
healthcare system it's working as a
collaboration across the NHS industry to
embed you know medicine into the NHS it
includes educational support and is
meant to leave this legacy structure in
the Health Service genome medicine
centers computational infrastructure and
a way of reusing genomics data and south
of course it will lead to new
diagnostics and therapies and new
opportunities for patients as part of
essentially personalized medicine
everything initially has to be done by
the end of 2017 that's the original
structure but actually genomics things
now extended release until the end of
the next five-year budget cycle to the
end of 2020 so fact this is really the
beginnings of national infrastructure to
support precision medicine genome
medicine in the UK so there's lots of
acknowledgments lots of different groups
across UK have contributed to the
initial pilot which Henry talked about
but it's the data that's been collected
in the first few thousand genomes
there's now quite a big team here at
genomics England of about a hundred more
than 100 people and as a large number of
external experts were involved in almost
continuously by xoring committees and
working groups and so it's a big
national enterprise now too which is
beginning to produce results we have fed
back some initial results and we will
start the pipeline have feeding back
individual interpretations and patients
over the coming months and I always stop
there thanks very much
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and the
first question is short reads miss a lot
of information do you think the UK has
sequins those 10,000 again using
nanopore or path file long reads in the
future um well then I'm back on the air
am i right so the short reads obviously
it's not perfect but it does produce
certainly a high quality I mean part of
the criteria for sequencing is a quality
threshold in terms of coverage we're
obviously going to have problems in
areas of structural variation to lessen
tendency mvs but something that most of
the variation we're going to capture are
we going to have to do this again well
the remember this project has it set up
right now is to provide treatments to
those individuals so if we get a
diagnosis and that's fine the additional
benefit of looking at those genomes
they'll be stalled maybe in future that
we sequence but the primary drive right
now is to use the sequencing
technologies available on the basis it's
good enough to have value right now
patients involved and empowered how are
they educated can we communicate and
collaborate with others in their
phenotype genotype to compare notes to
add more lifestyle context etc there's a
substantial activity to engage with
patients and the in terms of having an
interface of course this is all through
the healthcare system so it's through
the clinicians in the genome medicine
centers now there are ears a national
program under the health service to in
the next year provide everybody would
have access to the patient records and
to leverage some support on top of that
so in some ways a lot of this is going
to happen at the health service side as
opposed to purely genomics England but
we are in discussions around enabling
patients to contribute information as
well but right now you'll remember you
you think of 23andme those most of those
people they're not ill they're
interested in health and their interest
in their genome was here we're talking
about health service patients on the
clinical care and literally a lot of
them they just want to diagnosis how
many of the 5,000 whole genome sequenced
came from healthy volunteers and in
addition would you encourage blind
screaming of the general population in
England above a certain age so as I said
at the beginning we have a cohort of
health volunteers that's the UK biobank
and it's not sequenced yet but it is
it's a it's a comparative cohort which
some of which will get sequence of
course so that's as a population here
we're not sequencing any controls except
for parents what we do trios were
basically only dealing with people who
are ill in the healthcare system is
there any scope for other private genome
centers in the UK to play a role in this
project in terms of sequencing right so
in terms of private genome centers I
basically know this is this is really
being done as a centralized structure
now of course we're at the stage right
now where would only doing hundred
thousand I think as the health service
assuming the health economics on this
all looks good in the future then I
think we will be we will end up with
more than one sequence provider but it's
right now it looks that the most cost
effective way is to have a degree of
centralization even though you have to
transfer the samples you know you have
to build this infrastructure within a
health service to manage this but this
seems to be the best way of doing it
right now okay I can look at these
things now so answer the next question
it is it feasible to go so feasible to
go to 30 X coverage for cancer so I
understand I didn't point out that for
cancer were sequencing much more than 30
years for the tumor sample it's more
like 75 x if the 30 x is for the rare
disease studies and that's based on the
idea that when you do further yet
as an average you end up you can set a
very high level for a very high fraction
of the genome more than ninety five
percent at more than 15 x 15 x is what
you need to competently call heads in
the writing of the cases so that's the
kind of criteria wanted by the
computational environment we are
actually investigating using Hadoop
internally because if you think about
two and a half thousand p is coming in
with their postdocs and students want to
analyze this data we're trying to
provide interfaces within the system to
support analysis one part of that is to
read all the variants into a database
based on Hadoop so it can be rapidly
queries in query subsets so that's a
particular project being led by the
director bioinformatics or Guster Rendon
in terms of the general computational
everything is really that worked around
virtualization virtual machines a darker
environment so that everything that
people bring in as packaged so that it
will run inside the data center with
minimal intervention so when I thing
asked about what kind of international
collaboration is happening in parallel
so there are a couple I've mentioned
already the Global Alliance for genomics
and health that's really a project more
around how can you share data and
genomics in turn is part of that is
quite a lot of a UK institutions
including King's College specifically
for projects like the hundred thousand
genomes which is essentially a treatment
project the genome medicine project
there is another organization called g2
MC so it's the global
medicine collaborative so that's a set
of national organizations that have met
a couple of times last time of Singapore
in November looking at how genome
medicine techniques have been deployed
in health care systems and they were
very essentially the UK is almost unique
and during whole genome sequencing
directly in the healthcare setting but
there are other countries that are
deploying specific you know holding
national screening processes using
genomics for example very specifically
around detecting Steven Johnson syndrome
which is extremely severe immunological
reaction to drugs that leads to
essentially a very high death rate as a
immune reaction to the skin and you can
screen for that and in terms of the
health economics it looks like in some
countries where it's highly prevalent in
ER in Asia it's worth screening the
population in order to detect that so
those kind of projects you know looking
it were part of that sort of grouping to
exchange our expertise around how you
deploy this stuff in practical including
children so again you know emphasize
that the structure here is around unmet
clinical need so the types of patients
you will see normally in a clinical
genetics units that are health sillas
they're the ones that have this current
diagnosis rate through single d tasks or
panels and it's those that are eligible
if the disease is a clear phenotype and
it looks like you can you have a good
chance of providing an interpretation
using whole genome sequencing or so bad
into his children waves relevant under
those conditions in terms of right
cancel epigenetics so
the point here is so firstly cancer is
is coming on much more slowly than the
rare disease the project is really
focusing on rare diseases that moment
but that's partly around the difficulty
of talking here about standardizing
clinical processes in hospitals it's
been quite challenging to standardize in
rare diseases it's much more challenging
when you deal with the variation in
pathology services and the problems of
the current processes that are used in
cancer formalin-fixed fixation which
makes a difficult sequence so those are
the problems that are affecting cancer
program right now now do you need to do
RNA do you need epigenetics information
this project is very specifically only
to take whole genome sequence but we're
biobanking a sample is going to be
available for following investigations
on research side now we also are
investigating doing RNA in parallel with
whole genome for particularly for cancer
interpretation
I think you know so this is a question
now about some again cancer against
engagements of the patients I mean I
think I think you know page this will
this is basically out to patients what
they want to do there are a lot of
groups that exist we're ready to share
information between people who want to
exchange information about diseases and
you know there's nothing to stop them
doing that it I'm just saying that the
health service as a whole is starting to
share more information but it's not
specifically set up to to build a social
network I think others will end up doing
that i would like to once again thank
dr. Hubbard for his presentation do you
have any final comments to share with us
today that's fine I think that's just a
I think just to say that it's it's a
very exciting project and I think if you
look around what's happening in England
in London we have things like the new
crick institute just starting in fact
you know some part of London is now
referred to as tech city because it has
this huge collection of technology
startups around 2000 sort of area
actually roughly around genomics England
we have another side round the crick
institute which we're now referring as
makes it so this business of stimulating
SMEs around doing things with health
service data to improve healthcare
delivery and to personalize it genomics
is one
component of that but actually England
the UK london is really a great place to
do that kind of activity now so anyone
who's interested in being now pushing
this frontier and it really is a
frontier that we're pushing come and
look around and see what it's like to
come and work here thanks very much
thank you today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August of 2016 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you and this
webcast will be available for replay I
mean what you Deford that email that
announcement to your colleagues you may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye